Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In the film industry, we can often see footage
of a human walking on the Moon, fighting underwater,
or appearing in any environment without actually
going there.
To do this, a piece of footage of the actor
is recorded in front of a green screen, and
then, the background of the scene is changed
to something else.
This process is called green-screen keying,
and in theory, this sounds simple enough,
but make no mistake - this is a challenging
problem.
Here's why.
Issue number one is that separating the foreground
from the background is non-trivial and is
not a fully automatic process.
Let's call this semi-automatic because the
compositing artist starts drawing these separation
masks, and even though there is some help
from pre-existing software, it still takes
quite a bit of manual labor.
For instance, in this example, it is extremely
difficult to create a perfect separation between
the background and the hair of the actor.
Our eyes are extremely keen on catching such
details, so even the slightest inaccuracies
are going to appear as glaring mistakes.
This takes a ton of time and effort from the
side of the artist, and we haven't even talked
about tracking the changes between frames
as we're talking about video animations.
I think it is now easy to see that this is
a hugely relevant problem in the post production
of feature films.
And now, on to issue number two, which is
subtracting indirect illumination from this
footage.
This is a beautiful light transport effect
where the color of different diffuse objects
bleed onto each other.
In this case, the green color of the background
bleeds onto the karate uniform.
That is normally a beautiful effect, but here,
it is highly undesirable because if we put
this character in a different environment,
it won't look like it belongs there.
It will look more like one of those super
fake Photoshop disasters that we see everywhere
on the internet.
And this technique offers a novel solution
to this keying problem.
First, we are asked to scribble on the screen
and mark the most dominant colors of the scene.
This we only have to do once even though we're
processing an entire video.
As a result, we get an initial map where we
can easily fix some of the issues.
This is very easy and intuitive, not like
those long sessions spent with pixel-by-pixel
editing.
These colors are then propagated to the entirety
of the animation.
The final results are compared to a ton of
already existing methods on the market and
this one smokes them all.
However, what is even more surprising is that
it is also way better than what an independent
artist produced which took ten times that
long.
Similar comparisons are also made for removing
indirect illumination, which is also referred
to as color unmixing in the paper.
It is also shown that the algorithm is not
too sensitive to this choice of dominant colors,
so there is room for amazing followup papers
to make the process a bit more automatic.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!